everybody what's going on welcome to the
conan and cuba YouTube Q&A we are live
on the Internet
how's everybody doing I just like to
stir with clap that was so lame it's a
good energy it's a good it really isn't
the sound of there's nothing sadder than
the sound of three people in a small
depressing all the time exactly
we're here with writers Jesse Gaskell
and Jose Arroyo and of course Conan
O'Brien and we'll be taking your
questions for the next hour so I'll
leave them in the in the YouTube chat
below also please subscribe to our
YouTube channel you can find that link
in the description below and so let's
just start out just very quickly with
how did Cuba how did it happen how did
this episode even come about I'd like to
start first with my question what room
is this
this is where we're in a very we're in a
very depressing room where they shoot
the digital pieces I guess on the show
I've never seen this room before they
brought me in here and it was like the
scene where Joe Pesci thinks he's gonna
get made and I really thought they were
gonna shoot me it's so depressing what
are we in here for we have such a
beautiful studio here this is where we
shoot a lot of the digital stuff and
it's our little digital - social it's
also where a very depressed businessman
has an affair spent all the money going
to Cuba and now we're here on you can't
see over there but if they can turn
these cameras around it's the most
depressing room anyway please let's
continue with our version of Death of a
Salesman yes so on that on the on the
exciting of beat note of this depressing
room yeah I mean how did it how did it
come about you see that you've said this
before and other on other shows and
stuff but just for the people who might
not have seen that other media yeah it's
like where did the idea come from how
did it all kind of
how did it work okay look at this well
President Obama was a big story in the
news there has been an embargo on Cuba
and Cuba since well the revolution was
1959 I think the embargo is pretty much
in place by 61-62
so for longer than my life there's been
an embargo and then President Obama
announced that it was time to try a new
approach and they were going to try and
normalize relations with Cuba that was
in December
almost immediately after that I believe
Mike Sweeney our head writer said
wouldn't it be great if we went to Cuba
in the minute he said it I was possessed
I said we've got to go to Cuba
immediately it's such a great idea I
want to get there before the view or the
chew we knew that she went
we knew that Wheel of Fortune was gonna
go we knew it and I wanted I wanted to
get there first and so we were possessed
so a small group of us began working on
it how to make this happen and we found
a producer who does some work with
European production companies in Cuba
and he's based in Vancouver and he said
that he could help us and he knew how to
do it awesome and his name is Michael
Giacchino I was gonna say Jimmy no but
that's the director but she know the
Godfather so anyway he helped us we went
in two waves we brought Jose Arroyo and
we brought Jesse Gaskell because they
are both not only excellent writers very
funny writer producers but they also are
fluent in Spanish and we thought you
guys would be naturals and you were they
weren't you terrific made amazing
contributions and you deserve a lot of
credit credit you'll never get and how
much how much planning went in because
obviously you couldn't you were just
gonna kind of all go how much planning
went into what to do there
you know in terms of in terms of
research or beats that you guys thought
because you can't just arrive in the
night let's make it show so how did that
kind of come about how'd you guys come
up with those ideas oh it's pretty basic
we actually got guide books on Cuba just
to figure out what's in Havana what we
could look we could tour what we could
see what we could visit and we went from
there and then we you know we know that
Conan is is great in certain situations
and yeah just hanging out improvising
and so but the tour guides were really
are I don't know Wikipedia you guys
actually went on Wikipedia yeah it was a
lot of it too was just based on how do
we get permission to film in certain
places because right that wasn't I mean
they're not really set up it's not like
it's not LA word they have everyone
offers film permits right so there were
just specific things that we thought of
that that ended up not working out
because you know there's no possible way
to film right right so we also wanted to
kind of run in gun we wanted to stay
under the radar so yeah we didn't want
to be too conspicuous so we I thought we
rolled into sites pretty quickly and we
shot people were very unselfconscious
they were very gracious it's good and I
think that comes across in the in the
special and we basically just went
through a list and we chose what were
the things people watching right now
could probably figure out what would I
be what's a good environment for me and
so me learning how to do a sensual dance
well that should be funny sadly it is
funny me trying to sing is funny there
were just certain things we knew would
be a safe bet but we also had this
agenda from the beginning which is we
didn't want this I obviously do a lot of
remotes where the emphasis is on pure
100% comedy we wanted this to have a
sensitivity and a sweetness to it so we
did not pick solely for hard-hitting
comedy
we did not want to be snarky and we
really wanted to respect the people and
the culture and I think we achieve that
goal there's a that's the thing that
I've heard a lot of the feedback today
has been people noticing that it's funny
but not at the expense of anybody there
yes
the joke is as I'm more comfortable in
the joke is on me yeah and actually Jose
Lavin she asked how do you feel looking
back now do you feel honored that you
were the first kind of host to go there
or like now the via the episode is out
and people enjoy and if you yeah great
well I don't think honored is the right
word because that would imply that I was
asked by the government I feel lucky I
feel lucky that that we had the idea and
that I have the team that can pull it
off quickly I mean that for us our
executive producer was masterful at
jumping on it right away Mike Sweeney
our head writer was amazing
I've got terrific writers here that all
through in ideas
Jesse and Jose got the tone immediately
they're very sensitive to it and Jason
shal Emmy deserves a big shout-out he is
the guy that makes things happen on the
ground yeah he is like the the robot we
send in first robot that goes in you
know to the fire and please Kenny human
would stand Jason Salemi was as always
heroic and Jason Jason I think started
with me as an intern back in the 90s and
he's been with me ever since and he is a
hero and our crew I mean we had an
amazing those cameramen that sound guys
they were they're hauling giant
equipment and they made there's so many
beautiful shots shots where you're on me
dancing and then you pan over to a dog
barking and then we were able to make
that joke that ends the
right that was a such a great it's such
a sweet moment when dancing at the end
and then we undercut it so I mostly feel
lucky I feel lucky that we got to go I
feel fortunate that I had the right team
and I feel proud that I think we handled
this the right way
I'm very proud that I think we treated
this I'm with a lot of sensitivity and
and kindness it has a good spirit the
show and that he was important and
actually talking about kind of getting
in there and being a little run-and-gun
how did that the talk show desk kind of
come about that whole thing
that was such a great moment in the
street there and with the kid and you
know it was great is that we you guys
should talk about this but we we knew we
wanted to do something like that but we
didn't know where yeah
Michael Pacino found or somebody found
an old microphone that we knew we needed
and I brought the linen suit that's what
other than that we spent remember that
yes there's a morning where we're
looking for a location and we went to
one location it wasn't right we went to
another and then we're just looking and
then we found that Street and then just
you guys tell the story of how we
quickly turn that into a talk show set
well the idea was to do as spontaneous a
talk show table and chair as possible
and we thought well we'll find a folding
table and a folding chair that was even
that was hard to acquire at the last
minute the the thing with the Cuban
government is if you start setting up
something people will come right over
and demand papers are you reporters are
you here
are you authorized to film on this
street so we're walking down that street
that we wound up at and there's a cafe
there table all day there chair already
there so end of a war for great
vivacious women they had what's the name
of their band
Dave Dave up babe and we just said to
David would you be our band and they
said yes and and we pulled a cafe table
over we asked the cafe they said yes
some French women to leave their table
yes yes to leave and I always do that
whenever go to a restaurant there was a
great Jose and Jesse or Jose was writing
cards cards which I'm sure is a union
violation huh writing cue cards
furiously you know Jesse's hoping to get
it's the whole thing set up wrangling I
mean there were a lot of looky-loos that
watch the cameras we had in Cuba were so
big they were very there's nothing
inconspicuous about it so we look like
something official I actually think that
helped keep some people at bay it was
like oh they must know what they're
doing we didn't we didn't yeah we we had
we brought very good equipment because
another thing that we're very proud of
with the Cuba show is the even though
it's video I'm gonna use the word which
is incorrect cinematography but it just
looks beautiful
yes Cuba is such a visually stunning
place to shoot that we wanted to capture
that so we brought excellent equipment
yeah and you know we just didn't want to
shoot this there are scenes in the
special they're shot with Jose's iPad is
just Jose with his with his iPad by the
way the iPads a fantastic device really
big fan of the Apple watch coming but
but we were we threw that together very
quickly and what was fun is the people
in the background
I love the loose feeling yes a
caricature artist just walked up I think
you have it yeah he handed me a
caricature
on the spur of the moment it's the most
dreadful che Muller asks what was the
biggest mother or Muller meu I guess
Muller or Muller I'm gonna say Muller
cuz it kind of runs with Bueller right
yeah
what was the biggest culture shock of
your visit PS I Love You I one thing I
noticed on the very last day we were
there I saw a dog on a leash and that
was the first time I had seen a dog on a
leash dogs are just roaming that's
conducting business it's amazing you're
walking down the street and it'll be a
dog with no owner and it's just and
you're like you know hola he's like
they're doing their own thing there
they're out and about and it's
refreshing I was also struck by what
really the the lack of Internet yes I
think we take so much for granted here
and you keep looking at your phone and
Ren realizing oh this is a useless brick
was there any was there any internet
there at all at the hotel it was spotty
internet and you had to enter like 78
digit code access the Internet it would
then be open for available for you to
send one email you know to your loved
one to say I am I am still alive and
well and then it would shut down the
crumpled piece of paper and start
entering the 70s there was a window that
we could use the internet during which
you could use it and then also the
speeds the transmission speeds were much
slower than what we're used to you wow
that's amazing yeah I mean it must be
it's you guys actually had to talk to
each other
first time I've seen Jeff Ross lives
looking at this communicate with each
other but even those were very they
didn't work very well and one thing we
learned was they don't work when you're
driving well you're moving you can't use
the supplement is actually kind of good
that's yeah they should do that here
their worst thing is I was so that was
one of the most exciting things about
the trip is just as we were leaving we
were going in under the radar we were
doing this right quietly and just as we
were about to leave we were all assigned
to burner cell phones and you never feel
like a greater him when someone hands
and says here's your burner yeah you
have this urge to get mad you know and
then the minute you're done talking you
want to break it Muir is from German ah
there we go
you you live I'm German I see okay mr.
mr. Steve pick asked is there and maybe
there's not but what's kind of the
biggest misconception would you guys say
about you that the rest the world has
about Cuba not to speak for the rest of
the world but we can't I went it's a
very important distinction to make we
were in Havana we did not have the time
to leave Havana and go into Cuba Havana
and Cuba are quite different
we're told oh is that true yeah that and
so I just always want to make that clear
that we can't speak for the experience I
mean I agree you guys are always like
trying to say that if you go to New York
City that you've seen the rest of the US
oh it's very different so you were
brought you're actually hired for your
analogies yeah it was I was just saying
in terms of a misconception so you guys
kind of really only saw Havana which is
like yes so use metaphor man's metaphor
yes it's very tourist one of the things
is
America has been sort of locked out of
Cuba yeah so there's this feeling that
oh there it's an island lost in time I
think that's a misconception because
they're steadily visited by Canadian
tourists you know a European tourist
South American tourists I know they're
getting a lot of they're getting a lot
of contact with the outside world just
not with Americans ah that's it that's
it that's an excellent point and and so
was there a pressure while you were
there because you were only there for
such a limited time and you knew you
were kind of gonna do a show to shoot
everything or did you guys get to have a
little fun you know and go out to
restaurants or experience any of like
the nightlife like what was that like
like okay and then 4:30 a.m. immediately
back to see did we did myself less I
think I knew it I had to be on camera
so I would go you know I was impressed
with how quickly we started shooting
yeah we thought we don't know how long
we're gonna be here and we don't know if
someone's gonna stop us at some point
and we're gonna be asked to leave right
so the minute we got there we were a
little pac-man's eating as many pellets
as we could old reference look it out
but we we did our best to shoot a lot
but then when we were done with the
assignments for the day and we really
thought we've covered it we would get a
bite to eat and hang out I did drink a
lot of rum it's so good that I mean
after the mojitos are amazing the
daiquiris are great I mean you just I
just wanted to try every single run
during just straight rum and we also
smoked cigars why not why not I mean we
were on in some there were times where
all of us were sitting around smoking
cigars we would never do that in America
because it is when you see America and
there's a bunch when people in Cuba are
doing it's cool yeah if you're if you're
a guy doing it in America and you've got
a little
it's the poster for douche bag and I
immediately hate people that are doing
so we thought this is the one place we
can do it cool but you guys partied hard
I have to say and the cameramen our
camera our camera crew and sound I'm
surprised they're alive like we were
sort of there to kind of make sure that
you're partying jesse was selfless
altruistic party there's so much stress
during the day there was that it had to
be like there had to get outlet for it
and that was the night and and and the
they would our guys would the camera
crew I would see them for breakfast in
the morning and they would have come
back an hour earlier yes and they just
were wrecked and they would they would
be having like whatever breakfast was
available with you know they'd be having
like a croissant and some powering some
coffee and then they would go and take
there was a sauna a steam room somewhere
in the hotel and they would go and they
would sit in that for a while and then
be right back yeah Rumble it's mm
actually said it was less of a question
but thank you for letting them join you
for the Cuba screening so you want to
kind of talk about how you premiered we
had a little screening here in the
studio yeah I was happy that was an idea
I had I went as the show start to come
together and we started to realize we've
got something important yeah important
we have something that we're really
proud of and it looks beautiful
rather than we wanted to show it with
with with audience reaction mm-hmm
because that's how most people
experience when we show remotes on the
show we traditionally screen them for an
audience so that there's reaction to it
and I think that helps bring it to life
so we thought we should do that with the
Cuba show but let's do something special
so I had the thought let's dress up our
set with Cuban flags and palm trees
let's invite an audience especially to
come see the show
I think they did it through I think your
sister yeah my sister who does the the
audience for the show yeah we had a
contest yeah kind of contest and so
people in the contest when they came
they got Conan and Cuba hats they got
shirts and her food yeah everyone got a
nissan sentra no but every we gave
everyone shirts and hats and then we
showed them I came out and talked to
them and then in between where the
commercial breaks would normally be we
obviously didn't screen commercials I
came out and talked to people to try and
tell them the way I'm talking now you
know this is what happened this is
what's coming up next and give them a
fuel behind the scenes and then at the
end I wouldn't suppose to but I just
started taking questions and I think I
think you're gonna put that out we're
gonna put that out too yeah so that's
coming either tomorrow or or early next
week but yeah whole QA over Conan kind
of tells a lot of very juicy
behind-the-scenes tidbits about about
Cuba which is fantastic and one of my
favorite stories actually if you could
talk for a minute about returning back
to the US about kind of getting the
footage out because that was we shot you
guys shut this whole thing and now how
do we get it it starts with you guys
will tell it but yeah it started but 24
hours before we were supposed to return
home or less than 24 hours our producer
Jeff Ross was notified that a news
outlet had heard probably through
tourists that we that I was there and
they were gonna run with the story and
we asked them could you hold it until we
at least get out off the island with the
footage and they said you know we really
were afraid someone else was gonna have
it so we need to run with it and we were
uh nervous yeah that okay it's gonna now
be out it's gonna be it was a deadline
Hollywood and it might it's gonna get
around and it did become news yes I was
it was at the same time of the essent as
the SNL 40th anniversary so we were
hoping that that was getting so much
press that no one would really know but
it did get some press and then we
decided we
yes we split up Wow yeah we had them in
cartridges that came off the camera we
put those we back those up on portable
drives also on laptops so that if some
of the stuff got stopped by customs that
at least maybe some of the others would
would get through sure well and the crew
had gone through they went back through
Toronto and they had all the actual SD
cards and the camera equipment so
they're walking through with two
professional cameras and 15 cases of
camera equipment and customs immediately
pulled them over and we're like what are
you doing why did you did you have
authorization from the State Department
to go there oh why do I go through
Canada that sounds really shady yes so
they were interviewed for I think half
an hour before really good they finally
I think how they got out of it was they
produced a letter showing that they were
working with Conan O'Brien and then
suddenly the customs guys are like oh
what's he like thank you Thank You
Canada made in America I asked Conan
what went through your head when the
taxi door suddenly opened I was that was
a real moment I'm in the cab and Jose
was next to me our driver was laughing
maniacally I don't know why but he was
laughing maniacally laughs maniacally
the door just opened and I looked and
there was we're going along at like 40
miles an hour there's a lot of potholes
in the ANA and we're banging around and
suddenly there's nothing between me and
the street and I I just looked and I
just you know I didn't panic or anything
I just was like oh and I reached over
and I just shut the door and then
realized there's no seatbelts that's not
a thing well none of the cars have
seatbelts and a lot of the cars that you
saw on the special are from the forties
fifties they just don't have seatbelts
they haven't installed them since and
this car had no seatbelts so it was just
one of those things or if I'd been
leaning against the door I just would
have rolled out but I did and then it
was
you can see he starts laughing then I
just say hey I was almost killed
guy laughing shooting it all with them
[Laughter]
yeah it's almost like you setup that
moment like let's talk for a moment
about the food in Cuba a lot of people
ask me about the food and in the episode
you guys go to this thing called a
paladar which is and kind of explain
what the deal is there because
restaurants are all state-run correct so
yeah that's why you all the restaurants
are run by the state yeah and then
starting in I think twenty years ago
they started allowing people to run
restaurants out of their home if you say
I like your restaurant one of those
people they say paladar interesting it's
there they're very careful about that
distinction it's a loophole that allows
them to to run this organ you know run
something out of their home the food was
very good it's interesting when people
think Cuban food they probably think of
what you might get in Miami sure I think
it's very different because I think
there's different I think
Cuban Americans have changed things like
III didn't see cute like Cuban
sandwiches like you might get in Miami
it's just it's not the cooking tradition
it doesn't seem as evolved as it would
have been in Miami there's more
ingredients in the US are really limited
by what's available on the island and
what they're able to import so I mean
pork is really big I noticed like at
breakfast it was every incarnation of
pork fat on the street yeah a little
crackling oh that's fantastic
no but they pork they have there is huge
and they're using it and and beans and
so there was a lot of it was very good
really good fish
and we had we went to two Paulo dars one
of them is featured in the show we went
to another one the next night and both
meals were really good and you know
you're having rum with everything there
we go say like chandelier says co2
please do six hours a night on CNN
exactly looked into it the pay isn't
great is there is there any I know
obviously we went to Finland and then
and now we've been to Cuba are there any
particular places that that you would
want to go next a lot of people have
been asking is there anything out there
I mean this is a special circumstance
this was this was a special I mean this
will have its own flavor because a
country that this was so right
this was so perfect and then and I
really think it was important that it
happened would that we do this in his
one moment of time but I love travel
over the years through for a while
through NBC we went to Finland I shot in
Germany I was in Cologne and I shot
there I've loved and and Ireland I've
always secretly in the way in the back
of my head thought I'd like my show to
eventually one day morph into a show
where I'm not bound in a studio but I'm
all around the world yeah and that
Michael Palin oh oh yeah did it he did a
version event I thought I would love to
do my spin on that someday and you guys
can still be paid I know we make
metaphors and you know watch the
cameraman yeah no but I but I I do think
it's obviously we love doing the show
here and the Warner Brothers lot and we
love I still love the format of the wake
of the late-night format its traditional
and it's a fun form to play with and I
love I really do love interviewing
people and trying to find something
spontaneous in the moment
and so all of that's fun but I have to
say we definitely want to do a lot more
of this because it's invigorating that's
I mean everybody on staff not just for
the show but they do whole digital
department you guys everyone's been so
jazzed by the experience so hyped up
about it and excited that I think it's
led to a lot of ancillary creativity for
sure absolutely and all along those
lines too please go to Tim coca comm
slash Cuba
there's behind-the-scenes videos of
stuff that didn't make it into the show
and just these guys all hanging out
recipes recipes you can there's a
Where's Waldo
Edgar Shue asked Tony did you bring back
any vino Seco did you guys bring back
any souvenirs during that stuff or I
mean you know I have to say I was I did
one thing I I think you see it for a
second but there's a place where I'm
looking at books it looks like a flea
market oh yeah they someone was selling
Cuban badges from the past
I bought two badge I bought two
policemen's badges that look like
they're from the 40s and they say you
know Havana Cuba and then I bought one
badge that says Habana inspect or they
autoboot like bus inspector yes right
and I love the idea of having an
authentic look like a 1950's
badge that a bus inspector would wear in
in Cuba and I don't know what a bus
inspector working your way to I bought
jewelry said they had a some someone was
selling these really this really neat
jewelry that is made it's reproductions
of coins from before the Revolution and
so I bought something for my wife and I
bought something for my daughter
and I just bought a lot of real estate
well there's $100 later like there's you
can bring cigars back but there's $100
limit okay and the same sorry for rum
for alcohol and tobacco combined and
before I guess when people are used to
try to bring cigars back into the US
they would just take the price tags off
and say hey this you know 100 bucks yeah
but but now they're easing that up on
that and Jesse Jesse bought a mule yeah
we we've been looking at souvenirs to
have the chipper really wanted to buy
some and then never really had time
until the last day they were like at
6:45 we went out and we ran a 15 minutes
because all the stores were closing at 7
so it was like supermarket sweep yes I
ended up buying like 20 magnets and that
was all like erased my iPod and it was
terrible and all the bill was a racket
25 asks did any people have street
recognized you it must have been nice to
kind of walk around and be anonymous for
a horrifying horrifying look at how you
said there other tourists tourists yeah
tourists from other countries yeah
that's right you were stopped I don't
know what they don't want to know by
someone who remembered you from the
finland remote that's right
Czechoslovakian people and/or Czech
Republic and we asked how they had seen
the show and it was all online which was
called yeah a lot it did it was very
gratifying how many people from
different cultures different countries
would recognize me and say oh no we we
watch the show all the time
awesome through this medium which I love
yeah I think it's great that that it's
just nice for people to see your work
but I also would just get stopped by
people that you know six four and a half
with I look like a strange bird has
gotten so there were people that wanted
to stop me in Cuba just to see more
medical questions and and dumb question
but I mean are you guys would you guys
love to go back I mean you said you
didn't get time to really do much annex
definitely that's been a big theme of my
life as I'm always going to cool places
but they have to work the whole time
right and I would like to get outside
Havana I would love to see yeah I'm
fascinated to drive around and really
see more of the island thank you
beautiful so said to be some of the best
beaches in the Caribbean so I would love
to see that yeah absolutely and you kind
of make this you kind of make this point
in in the episode but in terms of how
much do you think the us coming in will
change the look of Cuba or do you think
I mean you kind of mentioned that
they're welcoming that the people the
people are welcome or well the people
are anxious for economic yeah you know
economic relief they they they need they
need it they they very much want to get
to know us they want to do business with
us that was the strong strong strong
sense we got just talking to people yeah
that's fantastic diem asked can US TV
baby aired in Cuba now did you anything
there to promote this no we can we're
going to do something cool why don't you
touch say what we're gonna do
well this well we don't know we may get
a chance to have our episode aired run
keep it's all the time the way that a
lot of people watch TV is they get jump
drives with like a terabyte of
television
terabytes a computer term oh and so yeah
so there it's kind of it's very
grassroots and as opposed to getting
satellite TV people will just write have
one drive that's passed around and
that's interesting you have to go to
pretty much an internet cafe a
government-run one and you pay a high
price but they look at yeah there's
severe wow it's even why are they
restrictions yeah yeah they're obviously
they're interested the government has a
pretty strict control I think what can
see and not see absolutely and so that's
something else that would be nice to see
change absolutely opening up Netflix
announced that they would start
streaming to Cuba I think that's going
to spread they can finally catch up on
orange is the new black yes Ivan I don't
even know how to say that last name Ivan
cool what do you think
cool yeah how many tasted for you to
cross this road that was kind of in
real-time I was waiting for a while and
couldn't get across and then notice the
cameraman was feeling me and that's when
I started but it's next to impossible to
cross the road and when I finally do it
was a little like yeah I think they get
government credits if they hear yeah
that was you know
loved is all the all the good moments in
the show and almost any every moment in
the show is completely real it's organic
yes we didn't set things up we didn't it
was which was nice as we we we went to
places that were rich and there's so
many in Havana but just rich with people
and they're very funny and they're
comfortable in there they're comfortable
in their own skins they're comfortable
with themselves
yeah me and they're very welcoming and
that just led to good comedy it was so
there was a lot of what I liked is
things like trying to cross the road or
all the babbling on the rooftop and
noticing people throwing doves and
there's so much where we just managed to
get lucky and find places where we could
something kind of interesting could
happen and I think that comes across on
the show is that you couldn't set this
up wouldn't it be impossible right and
that's another thing we didn't use any
stock footage so every car that you see
every beautiful Vista else was something
we saw in four days in Havana's no
except the part in the end of the show
with a death star blue blue what was
something and kind of moving forward
like do you think that this experience
has kind of changed the way you'll shoot
remotes are kind of what do you think
it'll give you license to do more of
this kind of genuine I don't think it I
mean first of all or was the time and
apply remotes a remote have always been
yeah very I mean if you look at even the
ones we've done recently going to the
spa was right that's just that's the two
of us and we going through and and and
experiencing those things all those
people are real right there there is I
think so I don't think it's gonna change
anything that way because there's always
been a real spontaneity to write to them
I think what what we are interested in
doing is it's made us hungry too
Rome even further afield yeah where can
we go what can we do
sure I mean I think going into this it
was all the question was can we pull
this off I think we happy with the
result which now makes us very now turn
in what was one thing you guys kind of
learned in terms of you know writing for
this remote in bed that maybe might
affect you in the future in terms of
giving you confidence in terms of things
you can pull off or will it allow you to
think even crazier ideas like we should
go to the loo that's the moisture so in
this particular case in many cases with
Conan on the remote I'm gonna speak as
if you're not here the comedy is often
found you just it's you create a very
sort of a general structure and then you
let him play sure and that's where the
comedy comes from so you don't want to
come up with oh then you go here and you
say this it serves you don't micromanage
it and then the the looser you are the
more I know the more fun you seem to
have and the more and the more
spontaneous the comedy is then people
can kind of sniff that it's real or
nothing analogy I've ever heard for what
the what they do and what I do is it's
their job to go out and construct a
jungle gym then I go out and play on and
I think what what we did you know and
and especially Jose and Jesse did is
they went ahead we had a bunch of ideas
of places to go and they scattered them
out and they went a day before and
scouted these areas and I think they
were as a group we were very good at
selecting where places I might be
comfortable and I was pretty much
comfortable everywhere yeah and what
happens is if you show up at a situation
then it doesn't it feels doesn't feel
right that's all you need
it doesn't feel funny and this comes in
remotes all the time you go somewhere
and you're just not feeling it or the
people seem uptight or it's you and it
is like we're like you know we're
looking for truffles and we don't think
they're here look over there and so but
I think Jose and Jesse did a really good
job of scouting ahead of time and they
gave me a lot of confidence because they
said oK we've been to this place right
we we saw the person you're gonna take
the tour with she's really good and I
think we think it's gonna be great and
they know me so well that that would
give me confidence and then I'd enter a
good situation it's not like I had to
scrounge around looking for good
situations we we had a good plan going
in and and and they really set it up
well cool what ends up being the through
line of something isn't what we
anticipate and the rum museum we showed
up thinking oh this is gonna be really a
fascinating sort of look and process and
then almost immediately realize this is
actually pretty dry and then my my need
for alcohol what's nice is that that was
real is that she uh she I think had
orders to take me on this very very
methodical to Museum and I think we were
ten minutes into it when I said is is
there a time when I get rum and she said
yes yes but the tour first and you get
that moment on camera
yeah actually see me understand oh I've
got my front line now yeah and then you
know which part of where which part of
the me not having wrong and then the
whole thing becomes I want my rum yes
and she's keeping me from my rum and all
good comedy or all good story is just I
want this I said that and you were
opposed and then finally people rejoice
when I finally got my Rob yeah playing
on the bar and Gretel singing tea shop
I know that nothing maybe one of my
favorites even though it wasn't supposed
to be we got there I there was a lot of
panicking taking place because I wasn't
sure that it was gonna pan out the way
we were right cuz it was unexpected but
then again like I said you kind of found
found the company there which ends up
ended up being absolutely mr. miles
asked how much sunblock did you bring to
Cuba I actually did bring it's no joke I
burn instantly so I mean I'd make a lot
of jokes about it but I did bring
serious sunblock the it's made by the
government it is the real deal it's
about like you know micro micro oxidize
zinc it I've got like a serious sunblock
just asphalt just yeah
and and that actually kind of kind of
brings me to the question of what
besides the white suit did you get the
white suit there did you bring it know
that all credit there goes to Bruce
Brummett awesome I'm sorry no you're
never to speak again I just wanted to
give props to Bruce brummagem he had an
idea to bring a linen suit and Bruce
Bromwich found some but they knew they
weren't right we wanted to classic Cuban
1940s white linen suit yeah and and then
just hours before we left
Bruce walked into my office with that
suit and I put it on and it fit
perfectly and he had these the shoes and
so I said you realize I'm I'm keeping
them I don't know I just want to wear
that suit but I'm sorry I cut you off
but no I don't know I was just gonna say
that we had a feeling we wouldn't be
able to find to fit you within in the
Cubans yes yeah yeah I look like pee-wee
Herman yeah I think we actually have a
great photo of him dancing oh that's
great and and was this
[Music]
and yeah and luckily but in that moment
is perfect I'm in this sort of Michael
Jackson which is something I can't do so
I don't know how that happened I mean
was that was that parade was that
something you guys came upon or you knew
yes all I need to do is like oh here I
go we had just wrapped taping on the
street and there was this touristy area
where these stilt walkers go by and it
just happened we just happened to
dovetail right at the time when they're
starting to to parade around and so he
and I he dances with you and I think
they didn't even know that you weren't
part of the group as we're starting to
kind of wind down here somebody else
kind of what was your favorite memory
either from the show or just from the
trip in general do you want to start
Jesse or kind of just to ask you the
biggest question and to throw you under
the bus I mean what was your kind of
biggest memory that you kind of took
away from the whole experience I mean it
really was magical I felt so just I it
was like we were it was a perfect
snapshot in time that we got to go there
and and everyone was so generous and
friendly and like I I do think maybe my
favorite moment is when we're on the
malecon and we see that these guys are
drinking box ROM oh yes I'm the
prominent there by the water by the
water and Conan asked what they were
drinking and you know they just offered
him there a box of rocks I think really
emblematic of what we found in Cuba
which is just people Oh what is that hey
do you want some you know there yeah I
you know the answer in improv is always
yes right and so when the guy handed me
the rum I just know after all these
years you drink you you drink the rum
and then the other guy hands me a
cigarette and you can see me start to
say well yeah you're not allowed to do
that American tone but I mean I start to
say no and then I just remember that the
answer is always yes I'm the next thing
you know I'm smoking a cigarette and
drinking rum with these
and it looks like a bad production of
grease it was but that was great I was
very very happy to see you know that you
can you can cross barriers I found this
all my life meeting you know sometimes
you'll you'll you'll get in a cab and
the driver is just from is from Ukraine
or you were who can part of the world
and they don't speak much English but
I've always noticed that if you're
humble and you're sweet and you keep
trying you can make them laugh and if
you don't speak their language and
people you realize okay that's the thing
it is at the risk of sounding maudlin or
corny it is I'm so nice when you can
connect to people through humor and you
see that there's an instant connection
and and so much of the show I think my
favorite thing was just these people
laughing and they're laughing at me
yeah or with me but they they understand
immediately that me trying to be erotic
for women and the runway is to be
laughed at yeah they know it instantly
yeah it's not like now this is a strange
no no that's just funny in any language
because I'm sure there's a Cuban version
of me
that's trying to dance with women in
shouldn't and it's very lonely inside
can you actually just very quickly speak
about that the nightclub scene there and
kind of what what happened that was real
yeah real nightclub you can people know
I don't think people know as a salsa
dance night they were having anyway they
are having it anyway I'm really serious
I mean but people go there like people
know that this is the place to go watch
professional level salsa and did they
know no yeah we did get permission that
I would get to dance there but no one in
the crowd knew it was a total surprise
and I was wearing that ridiculous outfit
with the see-through shirt and I had to
put that on a dress yeah I did there was
no place we need a dress so
climbed into our van and the lights
weren't on an advanced one and then I
put a coat over it and then I'm sort of
work Jose and I are working our way to
the side and get the camera set up and
I'm just a my only my concern when I saw
the the special was does it look like we
just staged this and it's fake because
it's because it's so it's shot and sort
of a flat shot for the silliness of it
but it was absolutely real it was real
people or at a real salsa nightclub it
was a big deal everyone's having a good
time and suddenly this madman dances out
and start and I started doing all that
stuff and then you just see shots in
people staring confused
I think the reactions you could
absolutely tell that people just like
was surprised I would say what was a
memory that you'll either from the show
or nothing take away ah well actually I
like the same thing the people were
great there was one point where we were
shooting a shot a sunset shot at a kind
of their version of a state park and
some officials came up to me and the
camera guy and they said you are
absolutely not allowed to film here you
must pack up immediately and I'm a
coward so I go all right
James turn off the camera and James goes
five more minutes and I went five more
minutes and the guy goes alright so he I
thought that was the coolest thing I'll
be back in five and he gave us the shot
this beautiful sunset shot that we had
been waiting 25 minutes to get yeah let
us do it so there was some you know
sternness in there but they also some
flexes and then Conan I mean honest we
spoke to this book and a lot today about
things you'll remember but is there a
specific kind of moment in time that
when you look back on this in a year two
years five years they'll be like oh that
was a certain memory of this kind of
tall trip wow it's hard to say if
there's one
because you're in such a because yeah
there's not I mean it's it's hard to say
there's one but I my favorite thing
about my job in general and about travel
and then when you combine the two is it
it's nice to be somebody else and there
are moments where you know I'm in a
linen suit and I'm dancing with a street
street performer and I'm in Havana and I
kind of look at the tapestry of my life
and think why is this happening I don't
know but I'm not gonna question it
that's it
I like those moments where I'm I've been
transformed into another person and
there's about 30 of those in in the
special and those are the things I'm
hungry for I'm like a shark I was always
hungry for the next moment where I'm
like in Finland I'm on a remember we
were shooting in Finland and I was on a
dog sled by myself and I was being shot
from a distance but I'm on a dog sled by
myself and at one point I passed the
camera crew and I'm just going across
the tarp the tundra in the Arctic Circle
on a dogsled wearing a big fur coat I'm
just looking around and I'm realizing
this is my life right now and I'm alone
yeah and there was a time I was shooting
a remote with mr. t years and years ago
it was a late night show and we spot of
a bit where mr. t is driving me in a
real open convertible a Rolls Royce with
no top the top down and mr. cheese
driving me and I'm in the passenger seat
and we're trying to get this shot and so
they told mr. t just drive along for a
while and we'll get the shot set up and
then you can turn around and drive back
and as mr. T is driving he's driving for
quite a while I get really tired and I
fall asleep
and then I passed out cold and about
five minutes later I wake up and I don't
know where I am and I just see fall
foliage leaves passing by me at 50 miles
an hour and I languidly turn over and I
see mr. t riding a car and I was looking
and I was like and you're thinking we've
all had dreams yeah beauty of my life I
think Cuba had a lot of that feeling of
yeah I woke up and I'm now in this
strange world I'm dancing with this
beautiful woman I'm you know looking at
appropriately far from my family
yeah well great well thank you so much
this has been amazing thank you guys for
joining us and give sorry about the sad
this is probably as good as it's ever
gonna go but thank you all for watching
for our YouTube coding in Cuba Q&A and
of course please watch the full episode
team koco.com it's great class Cuba it's
fantastic as well as you can see behind
the scenes stuff in photos and all that
good gravy please subscribe to our
YouTube channel in the description below
and thanks for joining us see you guys
later peace
you